ticulièrement fragile chaque jour la
france enregistre une moyenne de vingt
mille nouvelles contaminations et 1600
nouvelles hospitalisations avec hélas
320 personnes décédées ces chiffres nous
pourrions finir par nous y habituer
soyons cependant conscients qu'ils sont
très élevés et se traduisent par une
pression majeure et qui ne faiblit pas
sur nos structures hospitalières
aujourd'hui si malade sur dix
accueillies dans nos services de
réanimation sont des malades de l'aco
vide ce qui oblige nombre de nos
hôpitaux a décalé des soins moins urgent
pour libérer des lits
je veux à nouveau saluer l'engagement
remarquable des soignants qui reste
totalement mobilisée malgré la fatigue
accumulée
j'étais encore hier à leurs côtés avec
olivier ferrand dans un établissement
d'île de france et je ne cesserai de me
préoccuper de leur mission et de leurs
conditions de travail
si la situation reste préoccupante
elle se distingue néanmoins de celle de
beaucoup de nos voisins nous n'avons pas
connu au cours des dernières semaines de
nouvelles vagues épidémiques d'ampleur
nos chiffres sont certes élevé mais ils
sont relativement stables
le taux de mortalité par habitant liait
au virus
c'est au cours de cette deuxième vague
l'un des plus bas d'europe
la circulation du virus n'a pas
sensiblement augmenté au cours des deux
dernières semaines
le taux de positivité des tests restent
globalement stables
cela s'explique très largement par les
efforts par les effets pardon de la
stratégie que nous avons adoptées au
cours des derniers mois sous l'autorité
du président de la république et après
l'avoir soumise au parlement
nous n'avons pas attendu pour prendre
des mesures strictes dès la fin du mois
d'octobre dernier
nous avons fait le choix de ne pas les
lever complètement quand nos chiffres se
sont améliorés en fin d'année nous avons
su nous adapter dès les premiers signes
d'un début de reprise épidémique au
début du mois de janvier notamment en
avançant la mesure de couvre feu
18 heures d'abord dans certains
départements puis à l'échelle nationale
notre stratégie a été graduée
elle s'est adapté en permanence à
l'évolution de la situation tout en
restant responsable et cohérente dans la
durée elle nous a permis de garder
encore aujourd'hui le contrôle de
l'épidémie
tout en préservant au mieux la vie
sociale et économique de notre pays
ainsi selon les toutes dernières
estimations publiées par l'insee cet
après midi le niveau d'activité
s'établit aujourd'hui à 4% sous la
normale ce ralentissement économique est
moins marqué que ce que vivent
actuellement beaucoup de nos voisins
soumis à la même épée démis ses
résultats au delà des mesures que nous
avons prises tiennent aussi et surtout à
la grande vigilance dont chacune et
chacun de vous faites preuve au
quotidien comme ce fut le cas lors des
fêtes de fin d'année qui ne se sont pas
traduites par la flambée épidémique que
nous pouvions craindre cela est riche
d'enseignements car moins que jamais
nous ne devons baisser la garde
nous faisons face vous le savez à
l'apparition d'un nouveau risque celui
de la propagation des nouvelles souches
du virus que l'on appelle les variants
ces variants 10 anglais sud africains
brésiliens pour désigner les zones où
ils ont été repérés sont beaucoup plus
contagieux que le virus classique il se
propage donc plus vite touche davantage
de personnes et peuvent conduire à des
flambées épidémiques comme celles qui
ont frappé nos amis britanniques
irlandais ou portugais
ces variants ne constitue pas une menace
potentielle mais bien réel ils sont déjà
présents sur notre territoire et
progresse en terme de diffusion nous le
mesurons régulièrement grâce au système
de suivi que nous avons mis en place en
quelques semaines la part des malades
atteints par ces nouvelles formes du
virus est passé d'environ 3,3 pour cent
le 8 janvier
à 14 % aujourd'hui selon les estimations
avec des taux encore supérieur dans
certaines régions c'est pourquoi je
voulais dit vendredi dernier
l'émergence de ce nouveau risque nous a
conduit à nous interroger sur
l'opportunité de mettre en place un
troisième confinement le confinement
nous en connaissons en effet
l'efficacité au plan sanitaire que ce
soit au printemps dernier où au mois de
novembre
il a permis de freiner fortement
l'épidémie mais le confinement nous en
connaissons aussi le coût économique
social humain et parfois même sanitaires
nous savons tous aussi que plus le temps
passe plus les mesures de restriction se
succèdent et plus
leur impact est difficile à supporter
nous mesurons tous les risques
psychosociaux qui s'accumulent et auquel
il nous appartient de veiller très
sérieusement
et puis ayant bien conscience qu'un
confinement si on le souhaite
efficace signifierait très concrètement
la fermeture de beaucoup de nos
commerces mais aussi potentiellement
c'est de nos établissements
d'enseignement
à l'instar de ce qu'ont fait la plupart
des pays voisins la france
l'unesco vient de le reconnaître fait
partie des pays qui sont parvenus à
maintenir les écoles ouvertes le plus
possible depuis le début d'épidémie
je vous le dis ce choix et toutes les
conséquences qui l'a entraîné pour nos
enfants d'abord pour la vie économique
et sociale de la nation ensuite est à
mettre à l'honneur de notre pays et de
toute la communauté éducative à qui je
veux exprimer ma reconnaissance et mon
profond attachement
c'est pourquoi un nouveau confinement ne
peut s'envisager qu'en tout dernier
recours
la situation ne justifie pas à ce jour
notre niveau d'incidence est certes
élevé mais il reste encore très
inférieur à ce qu'il était en octobre
dernier alors même que nous dépistons
toujours autant vous disant cela je veux
être clair
si nous y sommes contraints en cas de
dégradation forte et rapide de la
situation
nous n'hésiterions pas à prendre nos
responsabilités l'objectif que nous
devons nous fixer ce n'est pas de
retarder cette échéance c'est de tout
mettre en oeuvre pour l'éviter j'en
appelle à la mobilisation des françaises
et des français
nous devons tenir ensemble nous devons
agir en ce sens plus que jamais nous
avons engagé une course contre la montre
avec cette épidémie
tant que la vaccination n'aura pas
produit ses pleins effets et chaque jour
compte et nous devons nous battre pied à
pied grâce aux armes dont nous disposons
aujourd'hui
d'abord en maintenant les mesures de
restrictions qui sont en vigueur
beaucoup de secteurs font l'objet de
fermeture ou de limitation et le moment
n'est pas venu de les alléger
je sais parfaitement que ces mesures
sont particulièrement difficiles à vivre
pour chacune et chacun d'entre vous et
tout particulièrement pour les acteurs
les salariés les professionnels des
secteurs qui n'ont pu reprendre leur
activité ou encore pour les étudiants de
l'enseignement supérieur je mesure et je
partage pleinement le désarroi et
l'impatience
car ce qu'ils veulent ce n'est pas
d'abord être indemnisés ce n'est pas
restée ces jeux c'est de pouvoir
travailler je le sais je le comprends
mais cela n'est pas encore possible car
l'heure n'est pas au relâchement de nos
efforts l'heure est au respect maximale
de nos règles communes
ces règles l'immense majorité d'entre
nous les respecte mais il suffit qu'un
faible nombre s'en affranchissent pour
que le virus
prosper causant parfois des conséquences
irrémédiables en raison de l'attitude
irresponsable de quelques-uns
il ne s'agit pas là d'une affaire de
discipline simplement mais tout
simplement de respect des autres et de
solidarité l'heure est au renforcement
de nos mesures chaque fois que cela est
nécessaire chaque fois que cela permet
de réduire le risque est d'être plus
efficace dans la lutte contre le virus
c'est le sens des décisions que je vous
ai annoncé vendredi dernier qu'ils
s'appliquent depuis quelques jours
premièrement la fermeture des frontières
pour empêcher les variants de pénétrer
sur notre territoire
depuis dimanche les déplacements à
destination ou en provenance des pays
étrangers extérieurs à l'union
européenne sont désormais interdits sauf
motif impérieux
pourquoi une telle mesure nous devons
empêcher que des personnes porteuses
d'un variante liste arrivée en france et
cela commence par éviter d'aller se
contaminer à l'étranger il ne s'agit
évidemment pas d'empêcher nos
concitoyens qui sont aujourd'hui en
déplacement à l'étranger de revenir chez
eux
il s'agit en revanche d'arrêter tous les
déplacements qui ne répondent pas à une
nécessité absolue
et c'est notamment le cas de tous les
voyages touristiques pour entrer en
france depuis un pays de l'union
européenne il faut vous le savez
désormais présenter un test pcr négatif
que l'on arrive par avion train bateau
ou par la route
en parallèle de cette mesure de
fermeture des frontières les
déplacements en direction ou en
provenance de nos territoires
d'outre-mer sont également concernés par
l'interdiction de tout déplacement sauf
motif impérieux nous ne le faisons pas
pour nous protéger cette fois ci d'un
risque accru dans ces territoires car
l'épidémie
il circule encore très modérément mais
au contraire pour les protéger d'un
risque de contamination en provenance de
la métropole de l'étranger comme le
montre la situation de mayotte qui a été
durement frappée par le variant sud
africain et où nous avons décidé
aujourd'hui d'une mesure de confinement
généralisée j'ai conscience que toutes
ces restrictions sont difficiles à vivre
surtout quand il s'agit de renoncer à
des projets de voyage ou de déplacement
mais c'est indispensable
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin reviendra tout à l'heure sur
les mesures que nous prenons pour
assurer la mise en oeuvre de nos
contrôles aux frontières ainsi que sur
le renforcement de nos contrôles demain
en général deuxième mesure vous le savez
d'encore la fermeture des grands centres
commerciaux qui constituent des lieux de
forte concentration et de brassage nous
avons tous vu les images de ces centres
bondée où les distances ne peuvent pas
être respecté et les risques
suffisamment maîtrisé nous avons
également renforcé les georges dans les
commerces de plus de 400 mètres carrés
nous veillerons évidemment à ce que les
salariés des propriétaires des 25000
commerces concernés soit accompagnée sur
le plan économique et social comme nous
l'avons fait depuis le début de la crise
pour tous les secteurs économiques
concernés
troisième mesure le renforcement du
télétravail il s'agirait en réalité d'un
levier très puissant que nous
n'utilisons pas suffisamment pour
freiner l'épidémie
le développement du télétravail est un
enjeu de fonds et de long terme dont les
partenaires sociaux se sont saisis dans
le cadre d'un accord qu'ils ont conclue
en fin d'année dernière et qu'il leur
appartient de décliner progressivement
dans les entreprises mais la crise
sanitaire exige de prendre des
dispositions urgentes et exceptionnel
télétravail est partout où c'est
possible devient impérative or depuis la
fin de l'année
le recours au travail s'est réduit ces
qui est d'autant plus regrettable que
beaucoup d'entreprises n'avait pas
déployé toutes les possibilités dans le
faire il y a encore trop de milieux
professionnels ou le télétravail serait
possible mais n'existe pas du tout à des
niveaux très faibles les administrations
publiques doivent en particulier montrer
l'exemple et j'y veillerai elisabeth
bornes reviendra dans quelques instants
sur ce sujet très important
quatrième mesure le recours aux tests et
à un isolement strictes il y avoue le
savent et quasiment pas de grip en ce
moment c'est une des bonnes nouvelles de
l'épidémie si vous avez de la fièvre des
maux de tête
la probabilité que vous ayez l'aco vide
est donc grande
au moindre doute faites vous tester nous
disposons en france une capacité de test
parmi les plus développés
p et les plus accessibles de tous les
pays européens les tests sont gratuits
disponibles à côté de chez vous et vous
aurez un résultat en moins de 24 heures
aux 20000 personnes qui sont détectés
positifs chaque jour je le redis isolé
vous immédiatement ne sortez pas de chez
vous pendant sept jours et des
l'assurance maladie à identifier les
personnes avec lesquelles vous avez été
en contact accepté la visite à domicile
d'un infirmier libéral qui vous est
désormais proposée et permettra de
tester vos proches à cet effet nous
allons amplifier dès la semaine
prochaine
le déploiement de cette stratégie testez
alerté protéger olivier et veyran vous
présentera dans quelques instants la
nouvelle organisation que nous avons
mises en place pour gagner encore en
efficacité dans la détection du virus
est remontée ces chaînes de
contamination comme on dit avec une
vigilance redoublée
quand nous identifiant des cas positifs
liés aux nouveaux variants cette
mobilisation générale pour freiner
l'épidémie
nous devons la tenir tout le temps
nécessaire pour que la vaccination
destiné à protéger d'abord les plus
vulnérables et les plus exposés à la
maladie est produit c'est meilleur effet
la campagne de vaccination a commencé il
ya maintenant plus d'un mois
la route est encore longue mais nous
avons déjà atteint et même dépassé les
premiers objectifs que nous nous étions
fixés
un million et demi de vaccination ont
été réalisées en janvier au lieu d'1
millions prévus initialement
il est exact que d'autres pays ont
démarré plus rapidement que nous mais
cela résulte d'un choix que nous
assumons nous avons commencé par les
publics pour lesquels la mise en oeuvre
de la vaccination est en effet la plus
délicate la plus longue
les résidents des ehpad et des unités de
soins de longue durée
mais ce sont aussi des plus fragiles
plus de 23000 d'entre eux sont décédés
depuis le début
de l'épidémie soit près d'un tiers des
17 auto alors qu'ils ne représentent que
1% de la population française d'ici la
fin de la semaine tous les résidents
volontaires des ehpad auront reçu leur
première injection 70 % de cette
population aura franchi cette première
étape décisive dans quelques jours et
elle sera totalement protégées d'ici le
début du mois de mars
à l'issue des deuxième injection c'est
un taux d'adhésion remarquable preuve
que notre stratégie dans ces
établissements était la bonne
le temps que nous avons pris début
janvier pour accompagner nos aînés vers
la vaccination était important il a
porté ses fruits
la vaccination est certes une course de
vitesse mais elle ne doit pas se faire
au détriment de la qualité de la
sécurité et surtout de l'adhésion de nos
concitoyens pour atteindre pour chacune
des priorités vaccinale le pourcentage
le plus élevé de personnes effectivement
vaccinés nous assumons à ce titre de
respecter le délai de trois à quatre
semaines entre les deux injections des
vaccins ryder et moderna contrairement à
d'autres pays certes peu nombreux qui
ont cherché à vacciner un maximum de
personnes en décalant à plus tard leurs
appels dont dépend pourtant l'efficacité
finale de la protection de vaccinale
nous ne ferons pas ce choix périlleux
sur le plan sanitaire et qui peut coûter
cher à moyen terme
la confiance est là de plus en plus de
français veulent se faire vacciner
nous pouvons nous en réjouir mais la
partie n'est pas encore gagnée
la campagne de vaccination suis
désormais un rythme soutenu très soutenu
nous avons vacciné hier et aujourd'hui
plus de cent mille personnes chaque jour
dont près de 70 ans première injection
il s'agit d'accélérer encore en
direction de trois publics
particulièrement prioritaires les
personnes de plus de 75 ans les
personnes atteintes d'une
pathologie grave et bien sûr nos
soignants auquel nous devons une
attention particulière car ils sont plus
que les autres exposés au risque est que
nous avons plus que jamais besoin d'eux
pour assurer la prise en charge des
malades
la mobilisation je vous le dis vous le
savez remarquable professionnels de
santé à l'hôpital est en vie agen des
agences régionales de santé des
préfectures collectivités territoriales
associations tous sont mobilisés pour
relever ce défi dans chaque centre
il y en a aujourd'hui environ un millier
en activité une équipe s'est constituée
souvent autour du maire dans un dialogue
constant exigeant avec les représentants
de l'état
je tiens ici à les remercier vivement
la campagne repose sur deux millions
deux rendez vous ont d'ores et déjà été
pris pour autant je n'ignore rien des
difficultés qui ont été rencontrés
la principale d'entre elles est là étant
liée à la déprogrammation de rendez vous
lier un retard de livraisons de doses
par les laboratoires en dépit des
commandes de contractualiser par l'union
européenne nous nous engageons à la plus
grande transparence centre par centre
territoire par territoire pour donner le
plus de visibilité possible au
déploiement de cette campagne vaccinale
mais comme les dernières semaines l'ont
montré la campagne de vaccination dépend
des livraisons des laboratoires et nous
oblige à nous adapter
c'est la raison pour laquelle la france
et l'europe agisse pour sécuriser nos
approvisionnements un vaccin déployer la
production sur le territoire national et
prévoir les étapes ultérieures
la ministre délégué à l'industrie agnès
pannier une hache y reviendra dans un
instant je mesure aussi parfaitement
l'angoissent de toutes ces personnes
âgées de plus de 65 15 ans qui n'ont pas
encore obtenu un rendez vous de la
famille qui les aide dans leurs
démarches ou qui attendent impatiemment
et parfois avec anxiété dans les rappels
et qu'on leur donne des réponses c'est
pourquoi je veux vous annoncer que nous
allons ouvrir dans les prochains jours
1,7 million de rendez vous
supplémentaire pour des premières
injections 500000 rendez vous fin
février qui seront ouverts à compter de
demain et un million deux cent mille
rendez vous sur le mois de mars qui
seront ouverts dès le milieu de la
semaine prochaine
ces nouveaux rendez vous permettront de
répondre
un grand nombre de demandes en attente
et seront suivis encore d'au moins 500
milles rendez vous supplémentaire sur le
mois de mars que nous ouvriront
progressivement d'ici là une fois
confirmé les dates définitives de
livraison d'ici avril
nous atteindrons ainsi l'objectif fixé
par le président de la république
d'avoir proposer la vaccination à toutes
les personnes de plus de 75 ans
volontaire et il faut qu'elles soient
les plus nombreuses possibles ainsi
qu'aux personnes de moins de 75 ans
atteinte de comorbidités graves
par ailleurs nous gardons pour objectif
de proposer la vaccination à toutes les
personnes de plus de 65 ans d'ici le
mois de mai est d'avoir couvert tous les
français adulte d'ici la fin de l'été
s'agissant plus spécifiquement des
personnes âgées de plus de 65 ans et
présentant des comorbidités les rendant
plus vulnérables à la maladie
je vous rappelle qu'elles peuvent d'ores
et déjà se faire vacciner si elles ont
l'une des affections pathologie parmi
les plus graves qui figure sur le site
du ministère de la santé
enfin comme vous le savez la haute
autorité de santé a autorisé hier
l'utilisation d'un nouveau vaccin en
france le vaccin
astrazeneca cela va nous permettre
d'accélérer le rythme de vaccination
grâce à ce nouveau vaccin nous pourrons
atteindre l'objectif de 4 millions de
personnes ayant reçu leur première
injection
d'ici la fin du mois de février
conformément à l'avis de la haute
autorité en santé
ce vaccin sera utilisé pour vacciner
d'abord l'ensemble des professionnels de
santé quel que soit leur âge
puis les personnes de 50 à 65 ans ayant
des comorbidités enfin l'ensemble des
personnes de 50 à 65 ans la première
livraison de vaccins
astrazeneca dès la fin de cette semaine
sera affecté aux établissements de santé
pour protéger les professionnels de
santé hospitaliers et de villes qui se
battent en première ligne contre le
virus et la vaccination
je vous l'annoncé devrait commencer dès
ce samedi les conditions de conservation
de ce vaccin moins complexe que les deux
premiers nous permettront de confier
ensuite d'ici la fin de ce mois aux
professionnels de santé de ville médecin
généraliste pharmaciens et infirmiers la
suite de cette campagne vaccinale
ils ont toute votre confiance pour cela
et cela nous permettra de renforcer
encore la proximité de cette campagne
vaccinale
j'invite le ministre des solidarités et
de la santé olivier ferrand à
approfondir en particulier notre
nouvelle politique de dépistage
ce ministre mais ce premier ministre
mesdames messieurs
on parle souvent du triptyque tester
alerté protéger je voudrais aujourd'hui
mettre des images des chiffres du vécu
derrière ce pilier incontournable de
notre stratégie contre l'épidémie
vous le savez la france est depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant
l'un des pays qui réalise le plus de
tests de dépistage co-lead songer un
instant que près de quatre tests sont
réalisés chaque seconde dans notre pays
dans l'un des douze mille points
existants permettant de se faire tester
grâce à l'incroyable mobilisation des
laboratoires des techniciens de
laboratoire des biologistes des médecins
des pharmaciens des infirmières parce
que nous avons fait le choix de laisser
l'accès aux tests totalement libre
c'est-à-dire sans ordonnance et sans
reste à charge ce que pour le coup nous
sommes l'un des seuls pays au monde à
faire
après une rentrée scolaire que vous
savez difficile au mois de septembre
synonyme de délais d'attentes
nous avons mis tous les moyens pour
faciliter l'accès à ces tests
priorisation des personnes symptomatique
large déploiement des tests antigénique
ont permis d'améliorer rapidement et
constamment la situation il vous prendra
en moyenne une demi journée entre le
moment où vous voudrez être testé le
moment où ce test sera réalisé et dans
92% des cas vous aurez le résultat du
test dans les 24 heures et même dans les
20 minutes
si vous procédez par des tests
antigénique nous allons désormais plus
loin
nous allons multiplier les opérations
collectives de dépistage notables
notamment en direction des
établissements scolaires en lien avec
jean michel blanquer remet également des
universités en lien avec frédéric vidal
de manière à renforcer l'acceptabilité
du test qui peut ne pas être agréable
quand on est petit nous attendons l'avis
de la haute autorité de santé sous dix
jours qui nous permettra d' employer des
techniques de prélèvement nouvelle par
prélèvement salivaire dans des
conditions que la haute autorité de
santé devra préciser sans attendre nous
nous équiperons et nous déploierons ces
techniques pour que retour des vacances
scolaires nous puissions réaliser
plusieurs centaines de milliers de tests
par prélèvement salivaire
seule la technique de prélèvement change
oublié dans ces cas-là l'écouvillon dans
le nez on prélève de la salive
en revanche l'examen se poursuit ensuite
en laboratoire de la même manière que
pour les tests que vous connaissez je le
redis nous ciblerons en priorité les
enfants et des personnes qui ne peuvent
pas bien supporté les tests par
prélèvement nasopharyngé classique en
revanche les tests salivaires rapide il
n'en est parfois question on peut être
interrogé ce serait formidable si on
pouvait disposer de tests salivaires qui
vous rendent un résultat en quelques
minutes mais à ce stade les études qui
sont pas très nombreuses ne sont pas
favorables à l'utilisation de ces tests
parce que la sensibilité des tests qui
existe aujourd'hui est trop faible
si votre test est positif vient alors le
moment de vous alerter c'est ce qu'on
appelle le contact racing c'est à dire
l'identification des personnes à les
alerter autour de vous que vous auriez
pu contaminer mais aussi la recherche
des personnes qui ont pu vous contaminer
sans que vous le sachiez
et pour de manière elle aussi à les
alerter nous renforçons continuellement
les moyens humains et techniques dans
les agences régionales de santé au sein
de l'assurance maladie
ces milliers de personnes formées qui
vous appelle dans les 24 heures dans 93%
des cas et vous permettre de prévenir
pour les personnes que vous auriez pu
contaminer afin qu'elle soit également
et dans les mêmes délais alertés à leur
tour et bien sûr l'application tous
antique au bide téléchargées par près de
13 millions de français et qui a déjà
permis d'alerter 60 7000 cas contacts
potentiels
là aussi nous allons plus loin désormais
pour agir plus vite plus fort via la
mobilisation de médiateurs de lutte anti
qu'ovide qu'ils sont capables de faire
du 3 en 1 vous testez initiés
immédiatement sur place
ce fameux contact racing et vous guider
dans votre mise à l'abri
vient ensuite le troisième temps du
pilier du triptyque la mise à l'abri
isolement des cas dont le test des
personnes dans le test est positif ainsi
que les cas contactez nous avons depuis
le premier jour vous le savez fait le
choix de la confiance plutôt que le
choix de la contrainte et de
l'accompagnement des personnes dans leur
isolement de sept jours parce que
parfois ça peut poser des difficultés de
se retrouver chez soi d'ordre sanitaire
ou d'ordre social ou les deux depuis le
10 janvier je rappelle que toute
personne positive qu'à contacter ou cas
symptomatique dans la tente d'un
résultat de test qui doit être effectué
dans les 48 heures peut se déclarer via
l'assurance maladie et bénéficier d'un
arrêt de travail avec une prise en
charge complète sans jour de carence
avec indemnisation
c'est un système qui est efficace trente
mille français ont fait appel à cette
télé déclaration en ligne sur le site de
l'assurance maladie
plus de dix mille d'entre elles ont
déclaré à la positivité de leurs tests
réalisés dans les 48 heures signes que
nous avons raison de faire confiance à
l'esprit de responsabilité des français
d'ailleurs nous menons des contrôles par
l'assurance maladie sans que ne soit
remonté de situations anormales à ce
stade
vous êtes accompagné si vous êtes mise à
l'abri contacté dans les 24 heures vous
l'êtes à nouveau à chaque fois que la
situation l'exigé
pendant les 7 jours qui suivent nous
allons là encore plus loin en vous
proposant depuis le 20 janvier la visite
d'une infirmière libérale ou d'un
infirmier libéral chez vous de manière à
répondre à vos questions
vérifiez que vous ne manquer de rien
tester si besoin les personnes qui
partagent votre foyer
dès la première semaine plus de 16 mille
visites ont été réalisées par des
soignants au domicile des personnes en
isolement et si vous êtes
particulièrement isolé sachez que vous
pouvez aussi compter sur le soutien
l'appui de quelques 1500 travailleurs
sociaux avec l'appui de vos communes de
vos départements
qu'il s'agisse d'organiser le portage
des repas chez vous de vous aider dans
vos courses ou pour la garde de vos
enfants pour vous proposer un
hébergement si les conditions de votre
logement ne permettent pas de vous
isoler du reste de votre foyer
pour vous accompagner et pourquoi pas
dans vos démarches administratives et
évidemment lorsque l'essai lorsque c'est
nécessaire vous apporter du soutien
psychologique dans cette période
difficile
je crois pouvoir dire que nous n'avons
rien à envier à nos voisins en matière
de tester alerté protéger avant de
conclure je vais vous parler de la
manière dont nous gérons cette menace
réelle et qu'il faut prendre très au
sérieux vous l'avez dit monsieur le
premier ministre
et comment nous justement nous
implémentons nous améliorerons encore se
tester à alerter protéger dans le cadre
des variants ces fameux variant du virus
qui circulent sur notre territoire
je vous ai déjà parlé lors d'une
précédente conférence de presse un peu
plus en détails du variant dit
britannique qui a la particularité
d'être plus contagieux mais a priori pas
plus grave même si certaines études
anglaises suggèrent que la pression
sanitaire pourrait être un peu plus
importante
les variantes sud africaine est la
variante brésilienne nous inquiète
encore davantage d'abord parce qu'il
existe moins de données sur les
infections qu'ils entraînent ensuite
parce que certaines études tendent à
montrer qu'il ya davantage de
réinfection et enfin parce que nous
manquons d'éléments pour être pleinement
sûr que les vaccins seraient par exemple
aussi efficace sur ces variants que sur
le coronavirus
nous connaissons habituellement dans
notre pays nous faisons très attention
je vous le disais d'autant que nous
avons objective et monsieur premier est
ce que vous l'avez dit des quatre
variants essentiellement du variant
d'origine anglaise lui on a toutes les
raisons de penser que le vaccin est
efficace et qui me donne pas je le
disais plus de formes graves mais nous
identifions aussi du variant d'origine
sud africaine est depuis hier quatre cas
de variants d'origine brésilienne
notamment dans le var dans la région
aura ainsi qu à la réunion
notre objectif est clair nous voulons
limiter au maximum la diffusion de ces
variants gagner du temps pour pouvoir
vacciner et protéger les plus fragiles
d'entre nous la stratégie est au fond la
même mais les moyens je le disais que
nous mettons en oeuvre sont encore plus
importants moyens diagnostiques d'abord
avec des nouveaux kits pcr dit multiplex
qui permettent de traquer la présence
d'un variant lorsqu'un test pcr est
positif mais aussi avec le séquençage
génétique massif des tests positifs qui
nous permet de suivre leur évolution
c'est ainsi que nous savons que 14% des
cas positifs correspondent à des
variants pour l'essentiel d'origine
anglaise
une fois diagnostiquée un patient
atteint de variants et contacter sans
aucun délai par des professionnels qui
sont spécialement formés de façon à
identifier les conditions de leur
contamination et identifier les cas
contacts et enfin protéger tout le monde
est cassé les chaînes de contamination
tout va ensuite très vite
d'abord pour garantir l'isolément des
personnes avec cette fois ci la
programmation systématique d'un passage
d'un infirmier ou d'une infirmière au
domicile du patient et l'activation
automatique de ce qu'on appelle les
cellules territoriales d'appui l
isolement pour vérifier que les
conditions permettent de garantir cet
isolement dans notre bonne situation à
la fin des sept jours d'isolement
la personne devra encore pendant sept
jours complémentaires limiter le plus
possible ses contacts porter un masque
chirurgical et être particulièrement
attentive à tous les détails dans un
certain nombre de situations il est
arrivé qu'un patient revenant de
l'étranger et dont les conditions
d'acceptabilité de la mise à l'abri
n'était pas assurée soit comme la loi
l'autorisé et sur un décret individuel
un arrêté préfectoral individuel me
soucie seulement contre 1 et encore
davantage accompagner
je le redis les variants parce qu'ils
sont plus contagieuses sont amenés à
remplacer progressivement le coville 19
dans la forme que nous connaissons nous
ne pouvons pas les éradiquer ces
variants parce que par définition il
diffuse dans le monde entier ainsi qu'en
france et ils sont plus contagieux mais
nous ne leur donnerons aucune once de
terrain
c'est dans une course contre la montre
c'est donc une course contre la montre
que mènent les dizaines de milliers de
professionnels mobilisés sur tout le
territoire national
et c'est une course contre la montre que
vous nous aider à mener en respectant
les gestes barrière en vous faisant
tester au moindre doute en participant
au contact racing lorsque vous êtes
appelés en restant chez vous si vous
êtes malade ou qu'à contacter il n'y a
rien qui relève du détail tout compte
si nous voulons tenir ensemble merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre du soleil
a été de la santé j'invite gérald
darmanin ministre de l'intérieur à vous
présenter l'application des dispositifs
de contrôle et de protection de notre
pays que nous avons mises en oeuvre
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs pour le dernier le
premier ministre a annoncé des mesures
supplémentaires couvre-feu pour lutter
contre l'épidémie
les prémices revient de l'est de les
rappeler et il m'a demandé d'appliquer
une intrigue ou rigoureuse application
pardon de ces règles qui je le sais
demande des efforts et des renoncements
pour beaucoup d'entre nous mais ces
efforts ne doivent pas être ruinée par
les dérapages de quelques-uns et c'est
pourquoi dès samedi dernier les
contrôles ont été intensifiés de manière
très significative et continueront de
l'être dans les prochains jours je
voudrais d'ailleurs remercié les préfets
leur équipe les policiers les gendarmes
les policiers municipaux qui mobilisés
dans des proportions renforcée pour
appliquer ces mesures de fermeté sont
tous les jours sur le terrain
il s'agit tout d'abord de règles du
couvre-feu et des contrôles qui
penseraient déplacements entre 18h et 6h
du matin le renforcement de ses
contrôles se traduit immédiatement par
des chiffres le nombre de ces contrôles
a augmenté de 39% le week-end dernier
par rapport au week-end précédent les
verbalisations augmenté de 53%
je rappelle que depuis le début du
couvre-feu c'est à dire le 15 décembre
quasiment 1 9 million de contrôles ont
été faits par les policiers et les
gendarmes et 177 mille amenderont été
notifié je rappelle qu'elle s'élève à
125 euros par personne par ailleurs les
nouvelles règles qui s'appliquent aux
commerces comme la limitation de la
fréquentation d'une jauge strict fixé à
10 mètres carrés par client désormais la
fermeture de certains centres
commerciaux ont été particulièrement
contrôlés et continueront de l'être avec
les services du ministère de l'économie
des finances et de la relance des
policiers les gendarmes et des préfets
travail au contrôle de 1964
établissement recevant du public par
exemple qui ont fait l'objet de ce
contrôle ce week-end deux fois plus que
le week-end précédent nous avons encore
pu être témoin avec bruno le maire avec
agnès pannier d'une trop forte affluence
en certains commerces
nous l'avons rappelé que l'application
la responsabilité de tous les
responsables de ces commerces pour
appliquer les normes sanitaires dans
leur établissement est très important
les contrôles se tiendront encore ce
week end pour pouvoir le rappeler le miz
économie a d'ailleurs annoncé que les
aides seront suspendus dès lors que les
commerces font l'objet d'une fermeture
administrative à la suite des violations
des règles sanitaires surtout j'ai
demandé aux forces de l'ordre d'être
particulièrement vigilants sur le sujet
des fêtes et des restaurants dits
clandestins et en premier lieu de leurs
organisateurs
ces événements de plus en plus fréquents
alors que nous savons qu'il favorise la
diffusion du virus peuvent anéantir tous
les efforts collectifs dans la journée
d'hier par exemple 587 restaurants et
débits de boissons ont été contrôlés
c'était 180 la veille de cette journée
ces contrôles seront encore renforcées
et je voudrais dire qu'ils ont fait
naître une réponse ferme à la fois de la
justice et bien sûr des services
ministère de l'intérieur 190
rassemblements festifs ont été
démantelés par les forces de l'ordre par
exemple et ont conduit à 208
interpellations et 56 156 pardon ont
donné lieu à des poursuites pénales
contrôler la propagation du virus c'est
également et c'est mon deuxième point
contrôlé évidemment nos frontières à la
suite des annonces faire appeler
monsieur le premier ministre
toute entrée en france et toute sortie
notre territoire
destination ou en provenance d'un pays
extérieurs à l'espace européen est
interdite sauf motif impérieux depuis
lundi depuis le début de cette mesure et
services de la police aux frontières que
je voudrais remercier sont pleinement
mobilisés dans les aéroports pour
contrôler ses vols internationaux 7 129
passagers au départ n'ont par exemple
pas été autorisée pendant deux jours à
prendre leur avion parce qu'il ne voyait
j'ai pas avec ce fameux motif impérieux
41 passagers arrivent en france n'ont
pas été admis sur le territoire national
pour raisons similaires
par ailleurs avec le ministre des
transports monsieur djebbari nous
veillons à ce que les compagnies
aériennes effectuées avec sérieux et
responsabilité le contrôle les motifs de
déplacement et la présentation d'un test
pcr négatif
le gouvernement n'a pas hésité et
n'hésitera pas à sanctionner durement
les compagnies aériennes peu
scrupuleuses sur la réalisation de ces
contrôles qui leur incombent en première
intention
avant les contrôles réalisés bien sûr
par la police aux frontières
al'approche de vacances scolaires les
opérations de contrôle les aéroports
sont particulièrement renforcée à ma
demande
ces mesures sont contraignantes mais
elles produisent des résultats depuis la
mi-janvier les dispositions prises pour
limiter les déplacements internationaux
ont permis de diviser par plus de trois
le flux de passagers des vols en
provenance ou en direction de pays
extérieurs à l'union européenne
nous sommes passés de 65 mille passagers
jour à vingt mille passes à ses
passagers jour ainsi limiter les
brassages de populations qui favorise la
propagation du coronavirus enfin nous
avons considérablement renforcé notre
dispositif aux frontières terrestres
depuis samedi
en effet toute entrée en france à partir
d'un pays de l'union européenne est
conditionné à la présentation d'un test
pcr négatif de -2 72 heures sauf pour
les routiers et les frontaliers
dès le week-end dernier des policiers
des gendarmes se sont déployés à nos
frontières pour contrôler les axes
routiers mais aussi les lignes
ferroviaires internationales
au total c'est quasiment six mille
femmes et hommes de la police nationale
et de la gendarmerie qui sont engagés à
nos frontières terrestres notamment pour
s'assurer que les passagers en
provenance des pays voisins sont en
possession d'un test pcr négatif
depuis lundi 102 mille personnes ont été
contrôlées à ses frontières
s'il 180 ont été verbalisés d'une amende
pour défaut de tests pcr
je sais que ces contrôles peut faire
naître dans le quotidien notamment pour
les frontaliers des difficultés j'ai eu
des échanges avec mes homologues
notamment mon numéro 2 belge ce matin
afin de les limiter mais ces contrôles
doivent pouvoir continuer de côté ou de
l'autre de la frontière pour limiter
évidemment les arrivées sur notre sol
la période que nous traversons est
évidemment difficile et elle demande des
efforts en premier lieu aux policiers
aux gendarmes et aux services de l'état
que je remercie au français qui pour
l'immense majorité d'entre eux
respectent les règles édictées
seuls ces règles peuvent à ce stade nous
permettent en effet de maîtriser
l'épidémie
elle implique la mobilisation des
services ministère de l'intérieur est
sous l'autorité de monsieur le premier
ministre et continueront aujourd'hui
demain et les autres jours à pouvoir
nous protéger merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
j'invite lisabeth bord du ministre du
travail de l'emploi et de l'insertion a
évoqué devant vous le très important
sujet du télétravail
madame la ministre merci monsieur le
premier ministre depuis le début du mois
de novembre
le télétravail doit être la règle pour
toutes les activités qui le permettent
cela signifie que si vous pouvez
réaliser toutes vos activités à distance
vous devez être en télétravail cinq
jours sur cinq aujourd'hui près d'un
tiers des actifs en france peuvent
télétravail est facilement et donc
participer à la lutte contre le virus
en télétravail ans il apparaît toutefois
que le recours au télétravail s'érode
progressivement depuis fin novembre
ainsi selon la dernière enquête réalisée
pour le ministère du travail
parmi les actifs pouvant facilement
télétravail et 64 % seulement ont été
travaillés au moins partiellement la
semaine dernière contre 70%
début novembre soit une baisse de 6
points 30% seulement de ceux qui peuvent
aller travailler à 100% le faisait
contre 45% début novembre soit une
baisse de 15 points
je sais que nous demandons un effort
considérable aux salariés et que pour
vous
ou le télétravail est difficile à vivre
mais nous n'avons pas le choix il faut
nous remobiliser car le télétravail est
un levier essentiel pour limiter la
circulation du virus
une étude récente menée par le
professeur arnaud fontanet indique que
les risques de contamination sont
diminué de 20% pour les personnes qui
sont en télétravail partiel et de 30 %
pour celles qui sont à temps complet
nous n'entendons pas revenir sur les
règles actuelles c'est sur leur
application effective par toutes les
entreprises et par tous les salariés
qu'il est indispensable de progresser
c'est pourquoi je demande à chaque
entreprise de se mobiliser sans délai
sur les deux priorités suivantes
la première c'est de réduire la part des
salariés qui ne télétravail pas du tout
les enquêtes dont nous disposons nous
montre qu'au moins un tiers des salariés
dont les postes sont télétravail à bhl
ne télétravail pas du tout notre
objectif c'est que ces quelques 2,5
millions de salariés se mettent ou se
remettent à télétravailler la deuxième
priorité c'est que les salariés qui
télétravaillent aujourd'hui un deux ou
trois jours par semaine
face au moins un jour de télétravail en
plus chaque jour compte s'agissant des
salariés qui télétravaillent à 100% nous
maintenant la possibilité de revenir sur
le lieu de travail un jour par semaine
pour celles et ceux qui en expriment le
besoin notamment s'ils souffrent
d'isolement
il est important de leur donner des
moments de lien social mais cela doit
rester une soupape en cas de nécessité
par ailleurs une étude réalisée par mon
ministère montrent également un
relâchement plus pop plus prononcée du
télétravail dans certains secteurs
c'est le cas notamment de la banque et
de l'assurance de la communication de
l'informatique des activités
immobilières et juridique
je réunirai donc les branches
professionnelles concernées en début de
semaine prochaine pour m'assurer que les
mesures nez
sergue ont été prises comme toujours le
bon équilibre se définit dans le
dialogue social au plus près du terrain
c'est pourquoi j'appelle tous les chefs
d'entreprise et les représentants des
salariés à organiser des concertations
au sein de chaque entreprise dans les
meilleurs délais j'ai envoyé hier une
lettre de mobilisation en ce sens aux
responsables des principales
organisations patronales et syndicales
pour que ces règles soient bien
appliquées
j'ai demandé à l'inspection du travail
de rester mobilisés depuis le début de
la crise elle a effectué près de 65
mille interventions sur l'application
des règles sanitaires en entreprise
les inspecteurs que je remercie
vérifieront systématiquement la bonne
mise en oeuvre du télétravail
à l'occasion de chaque contrôle je suis
consciente que c'est un gros effort qui
est demandé aux chefs d'entreprise et à
chaque salarié
je rappelle que nous avons lancé une
ligne d'écouté pour les salariés qui
souffrent d'isolement dont le numéro
s'affiche à l'écran mais cet effort est
nécessaire pour lutter contre le virus
tout en préservant la vie économique et
sociale de notre pays
chacun a un rôle à jouer c'est ensemble
que nous y arriverons je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
j'invite maintenant sur la question
majeure de l'approvisionnement et de la
distribution des vaccins
agnès panière une hache ministre délégué
à l'industrie à vous donner des
précisions
merci monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs je ferai d'abord
le point sur les commandes et les
livraisons
l'union européenne a à ce jour commandée
plus de 2,6 milliards de doses de
vaccins ces commandes sont fermes
ce sont des commandes qui porte sur des
vaccins qui dispose aujourd'hui de
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché ou
qui concernent des candidats vaccins
qu'ils pourront obtenir au terme de
leurs processus d'essai clinique une
autorisation
elles sont également assorti
d'options l'essentiel de ces douze je le
rappelle ont été sécurisés cet été c'est
près de 90% de ces doses qui ont été
sécurisés cet été par l'union européenne
avec le soutien des 27 états membres la
commission européenne continue à étudier
tous les candidats vaccins susceptible
d'être fournie rapidement dans des
centres de vaccination
elle vient de conclure deux pré accord
par exemple avec novavax éval neva les
trois premiers vaccins sélectionnés par
l'union européenne
c'était donc cet été à un moment où nous
ne disposions d'aucun élément sur les
essais cliniques ont obtenu une
autorisation de mise sur le marché de l'
agence du médicament européen
les européens ont ainsi accès au plus
grand nombre de vaccins ou un plus grand
nombre de vaccins que l'essentiel des
citoyens des autres pays
chacun de ces vaccins a par ailleurs
fait l'objet d'une validation rigoureuse
par une autorité indépendante qui
garantit la sécurité et l'efficacité de
ces produits de nouveaux laboratoires
janssen innova vax viennent d'entrer en
discussions avec l' agence du médicament
européen et espère obtenir l'approbation
de leurs vaccins dans les prochaines
semaines en parallèle nous nous sommes
assurés pour chacun de ces vaccins que
la production puisse être réalisé en
europe
l'enjeu est de garantir dans la durée
notre indépendance d'approvisionnement
c'est ainsi que l'essentiel des doses
aujourd'hui qui sont acheminés vers la
france sont produites en europe et en
europe compte tenu de ses perspectives
je peux donc vous confirmez que la
france sera en situation de vacciner
tous les adultes qui le souhaite d'ici
la fin de l'été comme cela a été indiqué
par le président de la république et par
le premier ministre je veux également re
dire une chose mettre au point des
vaccins efficaces et fabriquer des
millions de doses en moins d'un an est
une prouesse scientifique technologique
et industrielle cela n'a jamais été
réalisé
de mémoire d'homme nous sommes
maintenant dans une phase 2
montée en puissance de la production
cette montée en puissance de la
production conditionne l'augmentation de
nos livraisons
cette phase de massification de la
fabrication et notamment les transferts
de technologies qui sont nécessaires
sont une phase délicate et critique
si pour cela qu'il faut s'attendre à des
phases de mise au point de
ralentissement puis d'accélération des
productions dans les sites de
fabrication comme nous l'avons vécue
récemment dans les sites de bayod ntech
de moderna et d'astrazeneca
ces tensions sur la production sont
traités par les équipes européennes et
par les équipes françaises avec la plus
grande fermeté ce qui est paraît
évidemment normal
d'abord nous travaillons étroitement
avec les laboratoires et les industriels
pour les aider à augmenter leurs
capacités de production à multiplier les
lieux de production
c'est le sens de la réunion qui s'est
tenue mardi soir autour du président de
la république
deuxièmement nous contrôlons et auditons
les usines en particulier celles qui
peuvent présenter des difficultés pour
nous assurer et prendre la mesure de ses
difficultés à accompagner les
industriels
troisièmement nous contrôlons désormais
les deux exporté en dehors de l'union
européenne enfin nous veillons à ce que
les contrats soient respectés et que les
doses qui ne peuvent être livrés depuis
les usines européennes soit le cas
échéant livré depuis d'autres sites de
production il y à la négociation sur les
livraisons et la négociation sur les
sites de production il ne faut pas
mélanger les deux nous devons maintenant
mobiliser toutes les entreprises qui en
ont la capacité pour produire des
vaccins produire un vaccin ou un nouveau
vaccin pour des milliards de personnes
qui est un concentré de connaissances
scientifiques et qui repose pour les
vaccins arn messager comme celui dont
nous disposons aujourd'hui ce dont nous
disposons aujourd'hui
dayot ntech et moderna c'est à dire des
technologies nouvelles
ça ne se fait pas en claquant dans les
doigts il faut habituellement 18 à 30
mois pour réaliser ce travail
la france contribuera à produire dès les
prochains mois quatre vaccins en france
le moderna à partir du mois de mars
le bâillon ntech à partir du mois
d'avril
le curve ac si ce vaccin reçoit son
autorisation de mise sur le marché à
partir du mois de mai et le sanofi à
partir du mois de juin ceci le fruit
d'un travail entamé dès juin dernier
2020 par le gouvernement s'agissant des
vaccins moderna by one tech et cures bac
puisque nous avons accompagné et financé
les lignes de production dans trois
sites industriels français qui vont
accueillir ses productions sous
l'impulsion du président de la
république nous continuons à mobiliser
les laboratoires et les industriels pour
mettre en place de nouvelles capacités
de production
l'engagement de sanofi à produire 100
millions de doses en 2021 pour by one
tech annoncé courant janvier est un
exemple de coopération que nous avons
organisés que nous souhaitons renouveler
pour ce faire un commando vaccins sous
ma responsabilité directe qui réunit des
experts du privé et du public est en
contact permanent avec l'ensemble des
acteurs de la production afin de
mobiliser tous les leviers pour produire
plus et plus vite nous le faisons en
lien avec la commission européenne qui
vient d'annoncer la mise en place d'une
task force d'industrialisation et de
soutien à la production de vaccin sous
l'égide des commissaires kyriakides s
est breton tous les laboratoires et
sous-traitants sur le territoire
national ont répondu présents pour
participer à cette mission
c'est grâce à cette méthode d'action
coordonnée que lépine
les pays de l'union européenne sortiront
ensemble de cette crise qui ne connaît
pas de frontières merci beaucoup
madame la ministre mes chers concitoyens
gérer une crise sanitaire une crise
inédite une crise qui évolue à l'image
des variances est forcément concilier
plusieurs paramètres
plusieurs critères et rechercher le bon
point d'équilibré en sachant que
celui-ci évolue nécessairement au fil du
temps et de l'évolution de la maladie
elle-même mais de tous ces critères à
prendre en compte celui que nous avons
toujours privilégié c'est le critère
sanitaires
c'est la protection de votre santé ce
critère doit être le premier et il doit
le rester
même s'il nous conduit parfois à prendre
des décisions impopulaires
c'est là notre responsabilité et
j'entends l'assumé pleinement
comme je les ai toujours fait mais en
veillant toujours à bien prendre en
compte aussi les conséquences de
décisions sur toutes celles et ceux qui
en subissent les effets directement ou
indirectement
c'est le sens et mesures que nous avons
prises et ajustés au cours des derniers
mois et des dernières semaines pour nous
mettre en capacité de maîtriser
l'évolution du virus
ces mesures ont vocation à se poursuivre
c'est pourquoi nous avons intensifié et
nous allons encore adapter les mesures
d'accompagnement économique social
psychologique
jamais la solidarité nationale envers
eux et plus généralement envers tous nos
concitoyens qui sont dans la souffrance
matérielle et humaine n'a pris autant
son sens
et croyez moi lorsqu'on regarde ce qui
se passe ailleurs
la france n'a pas à rougir loin s'en
faut
bien loin en tout cas des éternelles
critiques et de l'autoflagellation à
laquelle nous c'est donc trop souvent
nous avons besoin d'un effort collectif
fort de civisme je dirais même d'une
mobilisation générale pour que nous
fassions reculer le virus les vacances
d'hiver débutent pour certaines zones
demain soir nous avons choisi de ne pas
limiter les déplacements entre régions
une telle mesure aurait été justifiée si
la circulation du virus était très
inégale selon les régions ce n'est pas
le cas pour autant plus que jamais nous
devons éviter tout relâchement comme
vous l'avez fait l'occasion des fêtes de
fin d'année je vous invite à la plus
grande prudence durant ses congés pour
celles et ceux d'entre vous qui pouvait
en prendre vous faire tester vous i
doser au moindre doute appliquer les
gestes barrière
respecter les règles communes plus que
jamais ces bonnes pratiques quotidiennes
sont au coeur du combat contre la
pandémie
surtout si nous avons la volonté commune
d'éviter un nouveau confinement c'est à
dire de fermer nos commerces où nos
écoles surtout si nous avons la volonté
commune de soulager nos soignants et nos
services hospitaliers nous sommes
engagés depuis des mois mais chers
concitoyens dans un long combat un
combat qui va durer qui n'est pas
terminée qui suppose résistance et
persévérance sens de la solidarité et
des responsabilités et je sais que nous
en sommes parfaitement capables nous
l'avons prouvé et nous le prouverons
encore il faut tenir ensemble je vous
remercie et nous nous tenons prêts
mesdames et messieurs avec ministre à
répondre à vos questions
bonjour le hic besson bfm tv mais c'est
le premier ministre
que dites vous aux français qui
s'apprêtent à partir en vacances et qui
ont peur d'un nouveau confinement
pendant qu'ils y sont parce que vous
avez parlé de la situation
elle est constante mais elle est
progressive en terme de contamination
dont de plus en plus de variants
susceptible de tout accéléré il ya déjà
des centres hospitaliers qui s'apprête à
des programmes et à partir de quel seuil
précis estimez-vous qu'un nouveau
confinement se justifierait et puis j'en
profite pour demander une petite
précision sur les contrôles aux
frontières terrestres parce que c'est
une question que beaucoup se posent
que se passe-t-il lorsque quelqu'un se
présente sans tester ce qu'il reçoit
juste une amende ou bien est-ce qu'il
est refoulé tester et peut être isolé de
manière contrainte
merci beaucoup une deuxième question pu
en voir répondre mais chez le premier
ministre bonjour cas nicollin pour tf1 a
essayé j'ai d'abord une question
justement sur les consignes sanitaires
me diriez-vous aujourd'hui que les
gestes barrière scrupuleusement respecté
pourrait être finalement plus efficace
ou tout du moins aussi efficace avec 1
re confinement et puis sur le variant en
glay une étude de l'inserm notamment
prévoit que le variant anglais soit
prennent le pas sur la souche qui
circulent actuellement en france à la
fin du mois au début du mois de mars
est ce que ce serait dans ce scénario
est bien une condition justement de
confinement pour rejoindre la question
nos collègues merci merci beaucoup
donc je vais demander au ministre des
solidarités de la santé de venir me
rejoindre puisque l'essentiel des
questions s'adressent à lui pu nous
viendrons à la question du contrôle aux
frontières terrestres sur le ce qu'il
faut qui était vraiment important de
comprendre c'est que ce qu'on veut
éviter c'est une épidémie dans
l'épidémie vous avez l'épidémie de kobe
de 19 qu'on connaît bien le corona virus
qui sévit depuis un an en france et dans
le monde
on en connaît les caractéristiques on en
connaît la contagiosité est il ya
l'apparition de ces variants il ya
beaucoup de variants qui peuvent émerger
dans un virus comme le co vide mais
certains on n'en parle pas parce qu'ils
sont moins contagieux autant contagieux
il ne se font pas leur place au sein
d'épidémie mondiale
et puis certains parce qu'ils sont
justement plus contagieux circule plus
vite et prennent petit à petit de
l'importance là où ils circulent jusqu'à
devenir majoritaire est la question que
vous posez au fond et c'est là qu'ils
ont la question que nous travaillons
constamment au quotidien avec les
scientifiques sur la base de l'observer
à l'étranger le portugal l'espagne
l'angleterre l'irlande l'allemagne tous
ces pays qui sont en confinement et avec
une des épidémies qui font rage
la question c'est qu'est ce qui se passe
effectivement si le variant kepu
contagion plus au cottage vieux pardon
devient majoritaire
c'est le risque de la vague épidémique
que nous voulons à tout prix éviter
raison pour laquelle il y a le
couvre-feu de 18h raison pour laquelle
il ya le renforcement des mesures de
gestion comme la fermeture des
frontières l'augmentation du télétravail
tout ce que nous pouvons faire et tous
ces gestes du quotidien
le respect des gestes barrières qui est
un levier puissant je ne dirais pas
qu'il est plus important et plus et plus
efficace que le confinement
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que plus nous
respectons les gestes barrière plus nous
nous éloignons la menace d'une épidémie
qui justifierait de prendre des mesures
de restriction collective comme un
confinement
donc c'est vraiment ça et donc on
surveille on voit que pour l'instant
effectivement le variant
anglais notamment il augmente petit à
petit dans notre pays le besoin
d'environ 50% par semaine grâce au
couvre-feu entre guillemets il
n'augmente que de 50% par semaine au
portugal par exemple ils augmentent
entre 80 et 100% par semaine en tout cas
avant qu'ils aient mis en place un
confinement
donc ce qu'on veut c'est le freiner le
plus longtemps possible à mesure qu'on
le frêne le temps que nous gagnons sur
la montée du variant nous permet de
vacciner davantage de personnes près de
2 millions d'injections été réalisés à
ce soir nous allons amplifier continuer
à mesure les deux arrivent comme l'a
expliqué à une espagnole une hache et
puis nous protégeons les plus fragiles
plus éloigné le risque que s'il devait y
avoir véritablement une épidémie de
variants elle n'emporte des conséquences
sanitaires importantes dans la
population
donc c'est vraiment ça c'est une idée
d'une course contre la montre chaque
jour que nous gagnons sans avoir
d'explosion du variant est un jour qui
nous permet de protéger davantage de
personnes les conditions météo seront
meilleurs aussi au fur et à mesure des
semaines on sait que le virus circule
manifestement moins facilement quand les
jours sont meilleures actuellement nous
avons plutôt une belle période
d'ailleurs en france donc c'est ça c'est
vraiment ça quand on dit de tenir
ensemble c'est ça monsieur me
l'intérieur pour les contrôles aux
frontières terrestres
mais alors il ya plusieurs types
effectivement de car d'abord à ses
frontières terrestres ce qu'il s'agit de
citoyens français français binational ou
français évidemment nous ne pouvons pas
refouler les citoyens français même s'il
n'avait pas de test et qui voudraient
rentrer sur le territoire national mais
évidemment une amende est prise ainsi
effectivement qu'une incitation très
forte à s'isoler
s'il s'agit de personnes qui est en
dehors de l'union européenne ou de
citoyens européens mais qui ne sont pas
des frontaliers nous pouvons une
instruction du premier ministre va être
prise et le droit européen ne le permet
évitez les admissions sur le sol
national et donc ne pas les faire
rentrer sur le territoire national et
puis évidemment une des exceptions que
j'évoquais les frontaliers et les
routiers qui ne sont pas soumis à ce
sujet même s'ils peuvent effectivement
être contrôlés dans le flux des passages
terrestres des véhicules
je rappelle d'ailleurs que pour les
étrangers qui viendrait de l'extérieur
de l'union européenne il peut f1
ne pas être amis du tout sur le
territoire national et réadmis dans leur
pays
c'est le cas notamment évidemment dans
le cas des aéroports ou dans des grands
trafics internationaux
oui je un vent doux c'est d'abord je
voudrais redire que par rapport aux
vacances je voudrais répondre à une
question que vous ne m'avez pas posée
puisque vous avez dans cette question
évoqué la perspective d'un confinement
qui surviendrait pendant que les gens
sont en vacances qui est une perspective
qu'on ne peut pas effectivement exclure
notre intention bien sûr et d'autoriser
les genres gagner dans ces conditions
leur domicile puis ça parce que c'est
une question qu'on n'a pas posé mais qui
revient de manière régulière et que je
voulais donc clarifié devant vous pour
cent monsieur le premier ministre je
m'habille peu d'eau pour europe 1 il ya
eu donc eu de ces derniers jours une
promesse de vaccination pour tous les
adultes à l'été est ce que cette
promesse ne risque pas de créer des
déceptions il n'y a pas un risque de
déception est finalement un risque
politique à faire ce type de promesses
vous en seriez ainsi que le président
comptable et puis pour compléter la
question de mon confrère de bfm tv sur
un possible confinement on comprend donc
que cette option est possible vous avez
noté probablement l'anxiété que la tante
l'incertitude crèche de très nombreux
français on avec une séquence il ya une
dizaine de jours où on a tous
collectivement cru qu'il y aurait un
recond finement imminent ont dit
certains ou en recrutement serré a dit
notamment l'un de vos ministres
est-ce que vous donnerez des signes dans
les jours précédents je fais juste une
parenthèse pour dire que ce n'était pas
uniquement la presse qui est inventé ça
ce que la presse a relayé c'était
évidemment les conseillers les ministres
qui en parlent et merci beaucoup
bonjour mais c'est le premier nul je la
mi-mars au delà afp quelques questions
justes pour les services de de la lfp
vous tablez sur 4 millions de personnes
vaccinées à la fin février des chiffres
dont on dispose on comprend que 8
millions de doses seront reçus par la
france à cette période là comment est-ce
qu'on peut expliquer ce delta même si
l'on comprend bien qu'une partie de ces
doses de ce delta sera pour la deuxième
injection
une question sur les traitements est ce
qu'il y a des espoirs en la matière est
ce que la recherche française qu'elle
était un peu plus à la peine sur les
vaccins à des espoirs d'être cette fois
ci en pointe sur la question des
traitements et enfin vous avait annoncé
500 milles rendez vous qui seront
ouverts d'ici demain
est ce que ce sont les 500 milles mêmes
qui avaient été annoncées qui aurait dû
être ouvert la semaine dernière très
bien j'ai envie de me la santé parce que
l'essentiel des questions le concerne
simplement par rapport à question d'
europe 1 sur leur confinement par
confinement que vous avez évoquées en
réalité ce qui crée de l'anxiété 1
messieurs dames comme toujours c'est le
virus et ses incertitudes
donc effectivement face à situation
actuelle qu'il y a eu des interrogations
je n'ai fait état dans mon intervention
je n'ai dit vendredi sur la perspective
où la possibilité de re confiné je vous
le confirme vous le confirme j'ai
également indiqué
nous avons dit que malheureusement cette
perspective il n'avait pas disparu
simplement pour toutes les raisons que
nous avons dit il faut nous donner
collectivement les moyens de l'éviter et
de tout faire pour qu'elle ne se
produise pas parce que nous nous soyons
tous bien d'accord il y a je l'entends
des personnes qui sont favorables
or confinement mais pas favorables aux
mesures que ce re confinement entraînera
nécessairement on les connaît maintenant
malheureusement nous avons une grande
expérience
qu'est-ce qui reste à fermer les
commerces qui ne sont pas des commerces
vendant des services ou des biens dits
de première nécessité mais vous savez
déjà qu'avec le couvre-feu à 18 heures
avec les mesures que j'ai annoncée
vendredi dernier
sur les les très grands centres
commerciaux on a déjà joué si j'ose dire
sur ce levier puis après les
établissements scolaires bon donc il
faut bien comprendre et admettre que
toutes ces dispositions entraînent des
conséquences y compris sanitaires y
compris sanitaires y compris
psychologiques qui sont très dur même à
laisser de côté les questions
économiques puisque je voulais dire je
l'assumé le sanitaire d'abord donc il y
à des questions qui se posent
il y a des interrogations liées
effectivement au virus en fait qui ne
varie pour l'instant nous avons dit il
n'y a pas nécessité de re confiné
appliquons tous ensemble tous les
leviers à notre disposition pour essayer
d'éviter cette perspective je pense
qu'il serait tout aussi malhonnête de
dire qu'elle est définitivement écartée
voilà c'est fait je crois aussi que
faire par année à nos concitoyens des
questionnements qui se posent des
incertitudes qu'il ya c'est aussi gérer
dans la transparence
cette épidémie c'est ne pas les
infantiliser dévoile à nous essayons de
prendre un moment déterminé les
meilleures décisions possibles pour vous
protéger et pour prévenir la progression
de l'épidémie
monsieur ni la centaine de questions je
crois qu'il m'était adressé un sur le
nombre de vaccinés à la fin du mois de
février souvenez-vous nous avions dit
qu'il y aurait entre 2,4 et 4 millions
de français qui recevraient une première
injection de vaccin d'ici à fin février
nous serons entre 3,5 et 4 millions de
français qui ont reçu une première
injection à la fin du mois de février
et vous l'avez dit vous-même il ya des
rappels de vaccination je vous donne les
chiffres de ce soir un million sept cent
soixante six mille premières injections
ont été faites dans notre pays
189 me rappel de vaccination ont été
réalisés c'est à dire près de 2 millions
d'injections
mais à mesure que le temps que les
semaines sans chaînes le nombre de
rappels de vaccination va devenir de
plus en plus important et lorsque nous
aurons plus de dos c'est à dire au mois
de mars on pourra augmenter encore le
nom
de primo injection donc les chiffres
sont bons et je rappelle que nous ne
gardons aucune aucun vaccin dans aucun
centre national tout est déployé dans
les territoires je vous donne un exemple
nous serons livrés normalement demain
soir avec les premières doses
d'astrazeneca 250 mille doses de vaccin
astrazeneca après demain c'est d'eau
seront dispatchés dans les 100 hôpitaux
qui vont du territoire national et j'ai
réunis ce midi l'ensemble du monde
hospitalier qui gère et qui pilote la
politique de vaccination en visio je
vous rassure et des jeux aurait demandé
à ce que dès samedi après-midi les
vaccinations de soignants âgées de 65
ans et moins avec le astrazeneca puisse
démarrer tout contrat pour le coup dans
un démarrage extrêmement extrêmement
rapide parce que tout est prêt et tout
est mis en place et ça fonctionne bien
deuxième question vous avez posé c'est
sur les traitements les perspectives
thérapeutiques n'êtes pas sans savoir
que le président de la république a
réuni les restes des responsables du
monde de la santé des grands
scientifiques mais également les agences
sanitaires ainsi qu'était laboratoire
pour envisager avec eux l'ensemble des
traitements qui pourraient être
intéressants et qui pourrait être
intéressant de tester aussi notamment
sur le territoire national dans les
jours et les semaines à venir de ces
réunions extrêmement extrêmement
productives ont germé un certain nombre
de pistes thérapeutiques
je pense notamment à ce qu'on appelle
des anticorps monoclonaux c'est des
médicaments complexes mais qui
permettent dans des études publiées
notamment aux états unis de réduire
l'apparition de formes graves chez des
publics particulièrement fragile
nous sommes en train d'avancer sur le
terrain nous avançons rapidement il y
aura des annonces qui seront faites
prochainement
c'est pas tout de suite ce soir mais ça
viendra bientôt merci les deux dernières
questions
le premier ministre mathieu des moulins
pour tf1 lci deux questions d'abord sur
la réouverture des restaurants et des
lieux culturels l'italie a été en mesure
de donner une date récemment est-ce qu'à
défaut de donner une date de réouverture
vous pouvez au moins leur donner une
perspective d'éclaircir une question
c'est sur les vacances vous avez parlé
d'un appel à la prudence mais les
français pourront éventuellement être
confrontés à des embouteillages liés au
chassé-croisé entre les différentes
zones
le week-end dernier plusieurs personnes
coincées dans les bouchons ont été
verbalisés ce qu'à l'occasion d'un
chassé-croisé il y aura une tolérance
merci beaucoup bonsoir romain cluzel
pour rmc une petite précision concernant
notamment les variantes brésilien vous
avez annoncé plusieurs cas détecté en
france est ce que vous nous expliquer
d'où venaient ces personnes à ce qu'elle
revenait d'un voyage à l'étranger
est-ce que des cas contacts ont été
recensés suite à cette détection par
ailleurs est ce que on sait si le vaccin
astrazeneca et efficace par rapport à ce
variant brésilien et sud-africains une
toute dernière précision le vaccin
astrazeneca pour l'instant n'est pas
recommandé pour les plus de 65 ans vous
attendiez des données plus précises
est ce que vous savez à peu près quand
vous pourrez avoir des nouvelles données
qui permettraient de d'éclaircir ce
point
merci merci beaucoup
alors je demande au ministre de la santé
de s'approcher à nouveau simplement sur
les lieux culturels et les restaurants
et les perspectives qui ont été demandés
bon donc c'est clair pour l'instant il
n'y a pas de perspective à court terme
nous travaillons
avec eux parce que les ministres
concernés les professeurs nous disent
souvent écoutée on préférerait que vous
nous donniez une perspective même très
éloignées plutôt que d'aller d'étape un
état bon j'ai déjà indiqué en tout cas
que je lui dis pas ce que vous pourriez
aussi posé la question pour les stations
de ski
je leur ai dit que de toute façon le
mois de février était définitivement
compromis la seule chose que je suis en
mesure de vous dire c'est que la
ministre de la culture roselyne bachelot
travail avec les professionnels est sans
doute à établir une distinction entre
les établissements en une vie culturelle
du circulant quand ça dira pas où on est
assis
dans un lieu clos par exemple les musées
où on pourrait avoir effectivement dans
ce souci de prévisibilité une ouverture
plus anticipé de crp que des ombres
d'accord donc ceci on y travaille on va
essayer de redonner de la visibilité
mais vous comprenez que la situation
actuelle 1 qu'elle nous trouve ans il
serait pas raisonnable de ma part de
parler de réouverture déjanire là pour
le coup n'y comprendraient plus rien bon
donc oui à des travaux pour donner des
perspectives non pour annoncer ce soir
des dates précises
monsieur le ministre sentez en train de
regarder une situation pratique pour
pouvoir être précis sur la question du
variant parce que je trouve que c'est
intéressant de voir comment fonctionnent
les équipes des ars et l'assurance
maladie quand je devais mettre des
images des chiffres derrière ce qu'on
appelle le contact racing j'ai par
exemple il ya un des cas de variants
brésiliens identifiés
c'est une femme qui revenait de manaus
au brésil où vous savez que sévit une
épidémie importante avec varian
brésilien n est pas rentré directement
en france elle a fait manaus sao paulo
san paolo francfort francfort paris
paris marseille elle avait été testée
avant le départ quelques jours
auparavant est arrivé en allemagne en
l'occurrence n'est pas en france
le détail est important parce que les
poteaux n'étaient pas forcément
identique elle a présenté des symptômes
peu après son arrivée en france et fait
tester s'est révélée positive comme il y
avait une alerte sur la possibilité
qu'ils des variants brésilien c'était
les premiers jours où il était vraiment
question de ces variants elle a été mise
en isolement en stricte avec visite
d'une infirmière à domicile
interventions des cellules territoriales
d'appui l isolement j'en parlais tout à
l'heure pour apporter tout le soutien
sanitaire social et vérifier que les
conditions étaient bonnes le contact
racing a été fait par la grèce
immédiatement une autre personne a été
identifiée qui avait voyagé avec elle
qui a également été isolés comme cas
contacts et un certain nombre de cas
contacts autour de ces deux personnes
ont été placées en isolement
le temps de pouvoir tester tout le monde
et en l'occurrence n'ya pas de chaîne de
contamination
un autre cas de variants de personnes
atteintes de variants brésilien je le
disais dans la région
auvergne et rhône alpes est une personne
qui avait voyagé et qui travaillent dans
les hôpitaux de genève
donc la rs cette fois-ci de la région
auvergne rhône-alpes à identifier
immédiatement des cas contacts au sein
de l'hôpital où cette personne travaille
dix personnes sont positives en attente
de recherche de variants et à chaque
fois qu'il ya une suspicion parce qu'il
ya un déplacement ou parce qu'il ya eu
un contact avec une personne qui était
en déplacement dans une zone où on peut
trouver du variant non seulement
isolement est vraiment strict avec un
accompagnement important mais il est
procédé à un séquençage génétique
c'est-à-dire que une fois que la pcr est
positive le test est positif on va
vérifier s'il s'agit du variant ou non
dans le doute on fait comme si c'était
un variant et lorsque c'est confirmé
bien on l'annoncent comme je laissais là
traite comme si c'était des virus qui
encore en circulation sur le territoire
c'était plus le cas pour le variant
anglais on y prête une attention
particulière mais on a davantage
d'éléments et d'information je le disais
et pour le variant sud africains
originaires du sud afrique du sud et le
variant brésilien on les traite
véritablement comme des nouveaux virus à
part bien monsieur le ministre
d'intérieur pour les questions de
d'embouteillage de tolérance aux
embouteillages
et puis nous arrêterons là mais très
rapidement monsieur le premier ministre
il est évident que chacun doit respecter
la règle est que cette règle fait qu'à
18 heures il ya un couvre feu et se
couvre feu c'est la situation n'a plus
satisfaisante je mets évidemment des
guillemets pour éviter les mesures de
confinement plus plus plus strictes et
que si l'attitude est laissée aux forces
de l'ordre pour entendre des excuses des
difficultés de sécurité routière que
l'on peut comprendre et qu'on a parfois
constatée évidemment elles ne peuvent
pas être une règle générale est dictée
devant vous donc à partir des vacances
comme en dehors des vacances il faut
savoir respecter le fait qu'à 18 heures
c'est aux français de s'organiser il
faut être arrivé à son lieu de
destination de même que nous fermons un
certain nombre de lieux de commerce ou
de l'activité professionnelle souvent 18
heures c'est le moment
non pas qu'on doit partir moment on doit
arriver alors l'attestation et les
papiers qui en général accompagne cette
attestation pour montrer qu'il ya des
contre-exemples et le prouver évidemment
aux forces de l'ordre
mais je souhaite effectivement que cela
sur le plus régler possible dans une
attitude laisser aux forces de l'ordre
dans le bon sens qui les caractérise
merci beaucoup
toutes et à tous